je crois
[Musique]
6h47 je vais éclater trouvé de l'été
j'ai pas le temps de finir de ditema
vidéo hier soir donc je me lève histoire
debout c'est un peu m
[Musique]
ok
là dans une des meilleures j'ai une
conférence avec dell petite présentation
cet après-midi interview avec un des
membres de l'équipe us de dell
bon ça c'est pas si je vous présente
aujourd'hui c'était le dernier pendant
quelques jours parce que cet après-midi
un événement qui m'intéressent vachement
tel ça m'intéressait maintenant je suis
libre et ça ça ne m'intéresse beaucoup
d'elle mais est ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il aille à une optique est
hyper shot sur le honor view vente sera
présenté le 22 à paris là il ya une
présentation qui se fait aux crs
toujours profiter sachant que ça est
aussi super cool
[Musique]
présentation américaine duo love you il
sera présenté le 22 lancement
international à paris et là il est
présenté en avant-première
tranquillement au mgm à las vegas
quelques jours à vendre ça c'est
vraiment intéressant
ça permet un peu de voir ce qu'elle
produit est ce qu'on peut faire avec
et franchement l'air très intéressant
nous entrons dans un endroit un peu
comme un duel please heineken 101
là je crois que ça va un peu mieux
il ya beaucoup moins de bruit pour
pouvoir vous en parler je suis très
content de pouvoir avoir vu ce
smartphone avant même son lancement
officiel à paris c'est franchement super
super cool parfait parlons du honor view
va alors moi je trouve assez intéressant
en tout cas je trouve qu'il ya un vrai
beau boulot qui a été fait au niveau du
design global
alors après on aime ou on n'aime pas le
fait d'avoir le petit poinçonnage dans
l'écran le dos aussi qui est un peu
particulier j'ai vous expliquer ça en
tout cas moi je trouve que ça va dans le
bon sens et c'est vraiment intéressant
parce que on avait eu déjà une
discussion sur un tout petit groupe avec
honor pour parler effectivement de
l'avenir du smartphone de là où va aller
le smartphone très clair que les usages
qui vont arriver le plus c'est le
multimédia le multimédia à des vidéos du
gaming youtube netflix
on voit que la problématique d'une autre
le multimédia c'est un peu moins ça donc
le fait d'avoir un petit trou comme ça
un petit peu son agent l'écran c'est
plutôt intéressant
parlons du design le design je trouve
vraiment intéressant ils ont un écran
qu'ils appellent le hall view display
c'est à dire vous effectivement un très
grand écran qui occupe la quasi totalité
du smartphone tout petits manteaux en
bas mais franchement il pas vraiment
très très grand vous avez cette petite
roue petits trous vous pouvez
complètement caché c'est à dire soit
vous avez le petit trou et la barre du
haut soit vous pouvez carrément le faire
disparaître comme vous faisait
disparaître votre encoches en gros sur
tous les smartphones qui en avait il le
compare d'ailleurs un l'écran samsung
c'est le infiniti or on sait que ça te
va sortir aussi un smartphone avec ce
petit poisson nage la techno des priori
pas exactement la même sans les rats
très prochainement lors des phases de
tests voir le chaos tout cas paraît le
plus intéressant le plus abouti que vous
invite à vous abonner parce que ça on va
reparler plus tard vous avez donc cet
écran de 6 4 pouces de diagonale c'est
un écran lcd vous avez un ratio de 19,25
9e et une résolution en full hd plus au
dos vous avez le aurora nadeau texture
intéressant pas mal alors après on aime
ou pas cette espèce de relief en v que
vous avez en fonction de la lumière
en gros ils ont comparé sa aux
hologrammes que vous retrouvez sur votre
carte bleue
c'est assez sympa ça c'est vraiment une
question douce et très personnelle on
aime ou on n'aime pas bon tout ça pas
mal bon vous ferez votre capteur
d'empreinte digitale au milieu la prise
en main de ce parti
le général très bien très facilement la
place pour mettre son doigt le module
photo est aussi très très très bien
situer trouve que le design là dessus il
ya strictement aucun problème c'est
plutôt sympa vous avez tout en bas de la
recharge en usb type c est tout en haut
du smartphone vous avez votre prise jack
ça c'est plutôt cool que la prétexte à
conserver en termes de performance tombe
sur un qui rident 980 forcément c'est le
dernier soc de hay silicone gravé en 7
nanomètres on a forcément de meilleures
performances au niveau 6 piles ou gipi
ou deux meilleures performances au
niveau de l'intelligence artificielle
est un smartphone qui globalement va
plus vite
on a deux versions sont une version 6 g
guin de ram 128 go de stockage soit une
version pro 8 gigas de ram 256 go de
stockage et en plus de ça on a le gpu
turbo 2.0 qui arrive toujours plus
rapide ou plus de calculs enfin ça c'est
intéressant ça va réduire les délais de
réaction de smartphones de 55%
enfin c'est franchement super cool au
niveau de vie ça devrait faire aussi
avec une énorme batterie de 4000
milliampères heures avec forcément de la
recharge rapide et pour votre smartphone
ne chauffe pas la technologie the night
qui est un refroidissement liquide dont
il devrait avoir une meilleure diffusion
la chaleur au niveau photo c'est très
intéressant on a deux capteurs en
arrière un capteur principal de 40 8
mégapixels
c'est le sony nex-5 186 c'est la
première fois qu'il équipe en
smartphones il a une ouverture de f 1.8
il à nouveau mode pour faire des photos
le premier mode symbole da la zone
artificielle ultra ils appellent ça le
hawaii ultra clarity en gros votre
smartphone moment vous allez faire les
photos ça faire plein plein plein plein
plein de photos en même temps ça l
assemblée pour vous sortir la meilleure
photo la plus claire qui soit la plus
jolie possible et a priori ce qui est
intéressant c'est trop souvent dedans on
devrait avoir aussi beaucoup de détails
avoir effectivement lors des phases de
test ils ont aussi un nouveau mode pour
la prise de photos de nuit avec de
l'intelligence artificielle
en gros vous avez une techno super
pixels vous avez qu'à pixels en un pour
capter encore plus de lumière et en plus
de ça je vous en parlais lors de mon
test photo du mail 20 pro souvent
lorsque prenaient des photos de nuit
vous avez cinq secondes d'attentes
il faut pas du tout bougé sinon votre
image va pas être terrible terrible donc
il faut poser sur un tripode sinon c'est
la galère ou en tout cas le poser
quelque part là il ya une stabilisation
de l'image artificielle qui devrait
corriger ça et ça que vous aviez
vraiment du détail alors on nous a
montré est en avance ou mais dans
l'image
on retrouve du détail ça effectivement
elle voir également les phases de test
le deuxième capteur c'est le 3d of time
of flight en gros c'est un capteur qui
va mesurer en trois dimensions qui est
capable de repérer l'objet est de
repérer le décor de tous repérés pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir des chalands de
l'application il faut pas le comparer
enroulée qui date de microsoft
du coup vous allez avoir des
applications avec de la réalité
augmentée pour du gaming
ça c'est plutôt intéressant il va
reconnaître les mouvements et vous allez
pouvoir par exemple sur la démo qu'on a
eu à jouer un jeu de fléchettes ça c'est
rigolo alors qu'il faut acheter un petit
dock en plus pour pouvoir le faire
votre coin sont craintifs a l'air d'être
assez marrant en termes de photos je
pense que ça va aussi permettre d'avoir
différents rendus sept ans est aussi
super cool et en plus de ça il ya un
nouveau mode c'est le calcul de calories
casal l'intelligence artificielle parce
que la caméra 3d pour pouvoir connaître
la taille exacte réel de ce que vous
avez mangé par exemple vous avez un peu
fils dans votre main vous le prenez en
photo sa connaîtra exactement la taille
d'une file du coup ça vous stimulera en
tout cas elle les calories du muffin bon
la limite de tout ça c'est
qu'effectivement il connaît pas le taux
de sucre qui a d'ailleurs dû me filent
bon notre casse en principe si elle
s'intéresse on est à la vente vous avez
une caméra de 25 méga pixels au niveau
de l'ouest c'est le honor magic dwight
qui tourne sur un android 9 paille
vous avez deux plutôt trois couleurs
différentes sur la version normale
vous avez le midnight black et vous avez
le saphir bout et sur les versions pro
vous avez le phantom blot et le fantôme
raid
en gros vous l'avez en noir en bleu et
rouge voilà il a le double gps
intelligence artificielle pour mieux
vous repérer dans la rue savoir
exactement où vous êtes tombons ces
petites fonctionnalités en plus mais ça
c'est rigolo
voilà moi je vois plutôt cool il a été
comparé au one + 6 t avoir effectivement
le testant ce qui donne en terme de
performance à billes je sais que ça va
franchement bien marché je connais déjà
le jpy turbo version un mec cool lg plus
turbo version 2 à mon avis ça va finir
déchiré je serai d'ici quelques jours à
paris le 22 janvier pour le lancement
officiel donc je vais me reprendre en
main le revoir ça d'être coup c'est
facile on parlera uniquement en français
là bas ça est assez rigolo et puis on va
les tester juste après ce smartphone
dont comme ça j'aurais vraiment
l'occasion de vous dire ce que j'en
pense enfin plein de tests au niveau
justement de les caméras 3d est assez
intéressant mais en tout cas ça va dans
le bon sens et puis le fait d'avoir ces
solutions on voit au niveau des petites
encoches c'est franchement hyper cool
alors autre truc est assez intéressant
il ya le hot d'or 8 x qui s'offrent une
nouvelle couleur c'est là
leurs fantômes bleus voilà ça c'est cool
je souffre aussi très jolie dans cette
couleur là voilà pour cette première
prise en main du honor view 20 juste
avant son lancement officiel ou
franchement c'est hyper cool merci au
nord amérique
[Musique]
pan de faire une petite pause pour
manger un bout j'ai pris une omelette à
force de manger trop frites je ressens
d'avoir plus de l'huile au fond de lui
que l'on doit le plus cool j'ai fait un
peu plus cool dr pepper ça la retarde un
duo parfait des livres j'aime beaucoup
ce joueur tient bien manger chez tennis
parce que je trouve ça quand même
relativement équilibré c'est bon c'est
pas grave
marc garneau si vous voulez vous et moi
j'attends c'est franchement cola fait
rendez vous avec dell dans 10 minutes
absolument pas que ce soit en retard non
mac casino dans béni jian j'ai cherché
le meeting space celle à 2002 ça doit
être par là bas c'est juste énormissime
centre clément sur toutes les machines à
sous
là on arrive à le récap arc et dès que
vous arrivez à l'oreca parc ce qui est
tout de suite impressionnant c'est tous
les logo french tech que vous avez de
tous les côtés la délégation française
franchement en met plein la gueule
il ya de plus en plus de logos french
tech regardez là les régions se
rassemblent et franchement c'est hyper
impressionnant
là on est sur le stand de mon pote steph
la monde connecté pour les enfants pour
faire de nos enfants des super héros là
mon petit mâle temps alors ça y est la
montre est dispo exactement on est en
voiture remake point tv depuis trois
semaines ouais
mais aussi des magasins magasins partout
alors l'idée de la mode connecté pour
enfants s'est passé depuis l'enfance des
défenses se dépense sur la défense il se
dépense
il se défend il se bat pour devenir un
super héros c'est ça en fait il va créer
son propre super héros ils sont peu
succès super pouvoirs oui celui-là c'est
mon super héros et que s'en servir dans
plein de jeux il ya des jeux aussi bien
l'éducatif que je prouve âge de la
collecte c'est fait pour faire pousser
jeu et ses activités le héros a besoin
d'énergie dont qui va s'ouvrir l'énergie
du porteur de la rue d'accord parce
qu'ayant les inscrits à faire du sport
avoir une étoile
bravo c'est cool bonjour meliana
description a franchement la montre
l'aller et non c'est pour les enfants de
calage décalage qui préconise les
enfants de 6 à 12 ans et de 10 à 12 ans
à savoir les leurs parce que votre
jusqu'au va avoir son propre smartphone
car l'entre-deux
bon c'est franchement cool je remets le
lien les jeter un coup d'oeil parce que
franchement ça c'est bien et même pour
les plus grands voiliers ces familles de
la sienne il est très heureux ya un
super héros si vous faites du doubs on a
souvent une sorte ou en trottinette on a
surtout des problèmes de sécurité pour
signaler quand est ce qu'on va changer
de sens à droite à gauche alors je sais
pas vous moi je perds ce marques comme
ça je tend le bras c'est toujours un
petit peu un petit peu dangereux là il
ya une solution intéressante
là on a des nazis avec moi les plus
capés du leak voilà qu'hier je fais
porter le truc dans do you keep cool
regardez pâle copie de la trottinette on
voit jamais quand vous allez tourner là
par exemple hop je mets mon clignotant à
droite
pilotant à droite qui me tend à gauche
tous les temps à gauche et là on a même
un anti brouillard donc ça c'est
vraiment intéressant pour tous ceux qui
vont le faire notamment la conduite en
moto s'est bien séparé mais aussi de
relever un peu le niveau de sécurité ce
n'est pas forcément en bas là ça se voit
beaucoup mieux et puis tous ces cons les
trottinettes c'est mon cas justement
pour pas galéré au moins vous dit vous
vous tournez à droite à gauche en temps
réel ça se voit c'est pratique et
sécurisée bravo merci guennadi c'est une
solution que les spolient tout de suite
pour les motards il faudra attendre le
mois de juin pour la trottinette vous
pouvez le trouver en ligne ici ss
prod like.com c'est le nom de la boîte
est la solution s'appelle clic light et
ça franchement pour la moto c'est
vraiment bien pour un tantinet mon avis
c'était vraiment indispensable lors
d'une solution qui est intéressante pour
la mobilité
c'est une start up qui s'appelle c'est
par là
anthrax alors l'idée c'est que vous
allez avoir des montres connecté pour
vous aider pour trouver votre chemin
donc pour la mobilité
là je me déplace on m'a dit que falloir
que je tourne à gauche dans 9 m je
continue mon trajet et ensuite j'ai la
deuxième au monde qui prend le relais
qu'il nie dans 25 mètres vous tournez à
droite tout ça vous permet effectivement
de connaître votre chemin et puis de
mieux vous déplacez façon plus
facilement et plus intuitive par
extension vous avez la même solution
également pour le sport et après vous
avez la même solution qui est égal face
à un prototype mais à des gants donc on
peut très bien imaginer pour du vélo
pour de la trottinette pour de la moto
c'est super intéressant parce que ça
vous permet d'avoir directement vos
gants dans votre champ de vision c'est
quand même bien en termes de sécurité
et puis ça vous renseigne vraiment sur
votre parcours donc ça c'est super
intéressant
les gars après une journée de cfa ça
c'est le bonheur absolu sion voulait pas
venir dans l'eau il ya gardé la piscine
comme elle est là avec la vue derrière
son mirage il faut savoir qu'ils
s'appellent les couilles
on se pèle rien du tout vu dans l'eau
regarder est ce que gm peut les quelque
chose là très original en fait
clp d'avoir de la nourriture et le lit
juste après le coup de la frite guillory
tu vois comme quoi ça existe vraiment
chaud
santé in french au gré des masses est-ce
que ça c'est pas juste énorme comme
belloir je pense que là vous pouvez
venir avec tous vos amis complètement
neu monsieur groen qu'est-ce que tu es
en train de faire bâiller se baigner
parce que aux crs le plus important
[Musique]
auquel il est aussi lyon je comprends
c'est pas toi
[Musique]
c'est même pas chez lui mais bon dieu
c'est quand même pas les grandes
température est vrai si j'avais bien
moquette chaud je connaisse les gars je
n'arrive pas et jamais ça va tout se
passe bien je crois que vous avez une
protubérance sur le dos monsieur de dieu
qui sait que ça va bien dans la faille
ce problème elle déjà plutôt d'être ça a
coulé on est dans les coulisses c'est us
la nuit pas trop de bruit parce que en
direct tout de suite avec stéphane c'est
pour moi tx watch connaissez watch donc
là ils font du 24 24 pendant le semestre
que c'est fou et là j'y passe dans cinq
minutes
il est dit combien il qu'à leur île et
00h21 avec tact ça quand même si la
classe sur le plateau il est quitte pas
sa caméra lui en avec je suis une zac te
ment sa présence et l'extension de ton
bras absolument on regarde comme c'est
bien pu freiner
voilà donc la nuit c'est la tâche et
confortable